heute ganz korrekt bevor das video
anzeigen für alle die aus eigentlichen
zeit gekommen sich vorschnell sagen ich
bin auch am 24 25
auf dem video date in köln kommt auf
jeden fall vorbei wird bestimmt cool wir
können paar coole fotos machen und so
weiter und so fort das ganze findet der
lanxess arena in köln statt
es gibt in der video beschreibung könnt
ihr euch gerne den link anschauen und
dann mal gucken ob ihm vorbeikommen uns
jetzt viel spaß mit dem video als wenn
das heißt hier mit ein produkt das ganze
geld wieder rausgeholt
[Musik]
jetzt bekommen beim ein video ja leute
das ist wollte ich noch nicht fertig
deswegen weniger sieht echt kommen schon
so sieht irgendwie auch cacaus sondern
fast enough leute herzlich komme ich auf
euch geht es gut mir geht auch gut dank
auf jeden fall der nachfrage auf diesem
fahrrad für heute was ja nicht ganz so
eilig hast du eigentlich selber überlegt
ich hatte es auf youtube gesehen ich
habe jetzt auch mitbekommen dass
handlungen paar mehr gemacht ich glaube
der erste wert gemacht hat war kann
kraft also darf ich jetzt einfach meine
inspiration her ich habe das schon vor
der woche gewinne oder so das ding war
ich habe mir dann auch im paket bestellt
weil ich mir dachte er das klingt
interessant ich verlängere ich dann
wieder auf jeden fall meine videos
stellung
auf jeden fall habe ich mir als bestellt
das problem war nur ich habe bei amazon
einfach meine adresse in köln und einmal
die adresse von meinen eltern hier und
ich hab hier hingestellt als es bereits
aus wenn man eltern und deswegen kann
ich das video hat jetzt wird dann müsst
ihr euch noch kurz das war's
wir haben hier jetzt das vierte paket
ich habe mir erst aber nicht kommen
fühlst du dir vielleicht einfach dass
die fünf tiroler berge führt 2 0
jetzt denkt euch wahrscheinlich erst mal
wieso ist das offen folgendes ich habe
mir das paket bestellt und dazu noch so
ein gorilla kostüm eine kamera mit
locken kann ich weiß ja wie das kennt
das paket kann morgen und ich hab mir
auch heute mein neues auto abgeholt und
ich hab mir gedacht vielleicht ist ja da
dieser gorillapod mit da drin
dann hab ich das auch so gemacht und
geschaut also wirklich nur einmal kurz
reingeschaut und dann habe ich gemerkt
das kann gar nicht sein weil oben
standen adresse drauf dass man von zwei
verschiedenen komm ich hoffe ihr
versteht mich gerade aber deswegen ist
das auch also ich hab halt gehabt ich
kann heute mit dem gorilla portion
bloggen damit verdeutlich einfach ist
und das video auch cooler ist aber dann
verhalten nicht so also der ist noch
nicht angekommen
deswegen ist das schon offen aber halt
nicht wirklich also das werdet ihr auf
wenigstens einmal zeigen
ich habe nur einmal ganz gut von oben
drauf geguckt und so sieht das auch ich
will gar nichts an aber ich bin wirklich
gespannt vielleicht ist er wirklich aber
ich habe schon wieder viel zu lange
gelagert
vielleicht ist ja wirklich was sehr
interessant ist was dann auch gebrauchen
kann
stellt euch mal vor dass das richtig
richtig kraft von kritik banken ich sehe
das jetzt einfach mal hier auf dieser
seite und
hilfe ist schon ganz schön schwer das
muss man einfach mal sagen so ich glaube
jetzt einfach immer rein und macht den
meister dann so gekommen
aber irgendwo uns anfangs handtasche
zimmer sich immer gewünscht mal woanders
haben bei der marke daniel rey
er drückt sich erst mal kurz mit ihr ist
er leute schaut euch mal diese tasche an
und ich habe hier einfach genau diese
taste gefunden und die kostet 19 euro
für 90 das tier mit einem produkt das
ganze geld wieder rausgeholt
ja ist also schon krass jetzt muss man
aber wir machen weiter
was ist das melt in dongguan guangdong
china kann mir irgendwann sagen was das
ist ich habe ehrlich keine ahnung
vielleicht hört das ja noch zu irgendwas
zum und wir machen weiter was ich möchte
noch mal mehr verzehrt entfernen obwohl
erst hier ist was zu alter klasse
ich hab nicht nur ein ich hab eine
fackel geil endlich eine neue trasse
fallen dieses mega groß da kann jetzt
immer meinen kaffee rausbringen
apropos kaffee so wir machen weiter
wer kann diese teile die man einfach
über die seitenspiegel markt das problem
ist nur die wm ist nicht ist ja ja
bereits auf ein ziel ist ja eigentlich
drin das ist ja megatrucks anlass ist
und was sagt ihr könnt euch niemals
tragen
auf jeden fall oder echt sie aus wie
eine fliege wir machen einfach mal
weiter
ist das denn nun sicher ein fächer ohne
spaß ich wollte schon immer ein haben
bei kennt ihr das wenns um megabit ich
kenne das jetzt aus köln alle in der
bahn habe immer so einen fächer außer
israel alter bekannter wieder absetzen
ich glaube ich bestelle mir gleich
direkt noch so ein paket für wasser malz
auch hier drin so klammern um hass
festzuklammern yahoo das heißt es für
die haare brauchen wahrscheinlich lange
haare für oder also dann sieht das
irgendwie so aus ich habe jetzt meine
frage an amazon stellt euch mal vor ich
werde franzose was deutschen dann mit
diesen sachen hier könnte ja sein auch
wenn ich in deutschland lebe zuerst
wechseln mal kurz die weiter als
nächstes müsst ihr könnt mir doch nicht
ernsthaft erzählen dass ich sie
reinpassen soll also ich probier das mal
kurz aber ich glaube nicht dass es
funktioniert ja geil geil jetzt habe ich
eine strumpfhose natürlich aber gar
nicht weiter an teams gebe ich auch
meiner mama oder mein bruder so als
nächstes sein dass locken sein
wittmund socken das sind ja mega die
fetten sachen zu stoppen
ich habe jetzt neue socken also wenn man
die anzieht da wird die echt nicht nur
wenn ich das ist alles zusammenrechne
dann habe ich schon so hat vom platz
gemacht mit diesem 20 euro zeigt nicht
das haben wir hier eine travel flasche
da ist der preis abgemacht worden so
dass in der serie braucht es nicht
so wir haben als nächstes land flohr
durch wärme und polstert für angenehmen
tragekomfort dank eines großen träger
als wenn ich sowas angedeutet um was
haben wir noch ein skelett und spendet
herr flash noch so jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt was hier drin ist ist erstmal
auf bekommen meinte kaputtgegangen
können
dankeschön das stelle ich mir vor man
dahin so leute als wenn dann kümmern
wollen ist von euch entscheidung sei
ernsthaft stellt euch mal vor das
projekt irgendwie sonst eher geschenkt
bekommen normalerweise müssen jedoch
sachen reinigt so für jeden zugänglich
sind oder mit dem heutzutage ist es mit
viel aufwand nichts fremdes mehr aber
sogar billy boy echten gute marken 24
stück gerettet meine woche mit
wunderkerzen
klopp noch so klein kam drin keine
ahnung was das ist habe ich vorher noch
nie gesehen brauche ich auch nicht
[Musik]
es sind solche sachen man denkst du echt
wer kommt auf die idee so was
herzustellen
die leute also eine perfekte wollte ich
immer haben
das ist das geilste darauf hey leute das
sind einfach handwärmer immer wer
komisch vor aber es im handwärmer und
sprache was auch teuer ehrlichen dieser
box über locker insgesamt eur wert oder
so dankeschön so und wir haben wir haben
noch ein brief vorgaben brief steht hier
drin gar nicht schön was ich verstehen
du willst es doch auch oder vw ist der
coolste an es ist der coolste wer macht
die besten youtube-videos alex diakonie
langen kanal nutzer keine beleidigung
alter perfekt für einen die mayday keine
freunde hat jetzt kann ich immer eine
dementsprechend durchgelaufen
das müssen wir noch was auch immer keine
ahnung und auch mit kette vor noch mehr
kette erinnern hier läuft hier läuft
richtig gewartet war
okay das deutet gewesen sein auf jeden
fall in die eine sommer sogar noch etwas
ist das hirn und herz an herz von so auf
jeden fall ist sie bis jetzt sehr ich
finde ich habe wirklich richtig was
abgeschaut
danke dafür amazon werner bock habe dass
ich das doch machen vielleicht dann mit
der 50 euro boxster samstag jeden fall
nach oben da und instagram wir sehen uns
dann übermorgen wieder übermorgen kommt
der block zu meinem neuen auswahl auf
keinen fall verpassen
ich bin so stolz darauf ist wirklich
mega mega grad und ich freue mich schon
euch das zu zeigen also wir sehen uns
haut rein
[Musik]